the real villain in last night in soho
isn't the spooky monsters our lovable
protagonist comes across it's time more
specifically it's the danger of
romanticizing the past while it's also
freaking jocasta but funnily enough her
entire personality is founded on
romanticizing horrible life events from
the past so yeah time is still the
villain and while some aspects of the
movie were a bit disjointed and edgar
wright probably relies on too many
twists this overarching message is
pretty unique for a horror movie and the
further you get away from something and
your tendency to romanticize the good
times and the bad times sort of starts
to sort of take away from the reality
of the decade so let's unpack why for
those who need reminding last known in
soho focuses on ellie an aspiring
fashion student who moves to london
after struggling to fit in she soon
finds herself transported back to the
1960s in her dreams where she follows an
aspiring singer named sandy ellie has
spent her entire life romanticizing this
exact era so finally gets the chance to
live out her dreams in the 60s but we'll
get back to this in a bit so clearly
time and romanticizing it is a pretty
big part of the film in fact to sandy is
essentially an embodiment of the past
you could argue that time is a separate
character in the movie but before we
dive deeper we've got to explore how
time or time travel is used within
different film genres sci-fi movies like
the terminator introduce futuristic
technology in enemies comedies like back
to the future highlight funny
generational differences and hit older
viewers with some sweet sweet nostalgia
romance films like about time and
groundhog day tap into the more romantic
or creepy side of repeating the same
date until you win over your crush
action movies like looper emphasize that
you can't outrun the past and highlight
our mortality and then a lot of movies
just say it and use time travel as
a band-aid relying on it to solve
complications from previous films with
no conceivable solution here's looking
at you avengers endgame and then you've
got christopher nolan who uses time
travel because well he just really
really loves time last night in soho
uses time travel as a way to literally
compare the past or the present and
highlights the basic human instinct to
block out bad memories in favor of the
good for example when i look back on
high school i remember it as a pretty
fun time hanging out with friends
partying whatever but in the moment i'm
pretty sure i wasn't having fun studying
stress i've just blocked out all those
bad memories here ellie is obsessed with
the 60s she listens to music she loves
the fashion she wishes she lived back
then then she gets to experience it
through her dream world as she is
transported back to sandy's life first
this only strengthens ellie's passion
for the 1960s as she changes her hair
card starts ordering fancy drinks and
tries to use some of sandy's phrases to
her present-day london is the bad place
with creepy taxi drivers and handsy
college boys in her mission to escape
she essentially tries to become sandy a
woman she idolises and envies however
the longer ellie spends in the past the
more she realizes that it was a horrible
time for women and the materialistic
things she associates with the 60s her
music and fashion don't portray the dark
reality sandy is used and abused and
becomes a sex slave in exchange for the
false promises of progression within her
career the facade of the memory of the
60s is wiped away and she's just left
with the horrific reality but the
message isn't as simple as past equals
bad present equals good it's the fact
that humanity seems to romanticize
events in errors that were objectively
bad times for example westerns try and
transport us back to the wild west with
exciting gunslingers and heroes rescuing
damsels in distress in reality there was
racism sexism and the life expectancy
was about 45 it wasn't a fun time in
last night in soho ellie has
conversations with a few other
characters about the past her
grandmother seems like the only one who
remembers it in a negative light while
the others look back on it fondly her
boss a bartender says she just remembers
the good times at the pub while the
creepy old man who follows her around
recalls knowing all the girls and seems
to look back on it fondly as well in the
final after the film ellie is unable to
escape the past even in her walking
hours this is clearly symbolic of what
would happen to our psyches if we were
unable to forget the horrors of the past
and i thought this was a really clever
and unique idea by edgar wright that's
all i'm looking for in a movie and yeah
i enjoyed it enough to look past any
other faults in the film let me know
what you thought down below and i'll
catch you in the next one see you gang